thanks to Wix for keeping legal eagle in
the air and our website on the web I
don't believe it
y'all meant to come down here and defend
me against these characters I'm the only
one I've got on my side is the blood
sucking lawyer I take offense at that
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer welcome back to laws broken
where an attorney destroys your favorite
childhood movies by showing you how
illegal everything is because everything
is illegal Wanda but this week we're
going to examine Jurassic Park as Ian
Malcolm would say it's like Disneyland
if the Pirates of the Caribbean ate all
the tourists there will be negligence be
sure to subscribe and comment in the
form of an objection which I will either
sustain or overrule and stick around
until the end of the video where I give
a verdict for John Hammonds civil
liabilities and how long Dennis Nedry
would go to jail we spared no expense
spent no expense spared no expense the
bottom line is that expenses were spared
[Music]
let's examine the evidence okay starting
off with a bang here I am pretty
confident that OSHA regulations do not
permit you to have a loaded shotgun as
well as dozens of men surrounded with
cattle prods that seems like a very
dangerous working condition that
probably violates a number of health and
safety codes this is clearly an unsafe
working environment that is going to
lead to numerous on-the-job accidents
and injuries of course at least they are
wearing hard hats which would make sense
if this were a construction site but
this is more like a zoo so I think those
particular hard hats in addition to not
making sense in this context probably
make things more dangerous given that
they're not going to do anything to
protect themselves from the
velociraptors so their heads in the
right spot but they have no idea what
they're doing and they are certainly not
OSHA compliant
[Music]
but at least unlike Willy Wonka at least
they were smart enough to put OSHA
compliant handrails on their buildings
[Music]
well loading team step away so in
addition to shotguns and Tasers a lot of
these men are armed with automatic m16s
I kind of doubt there are any zoos in
the world that equipped their zookeepers
with cattle prods and automatic weapons
that seems counterproductive
so that seems like a terribly designed
system I'm sorry I shouldn't laugh at
this carnage okay so there are a lot of
problems here
first of all whoever designed this
system did a terrible job because simply
by the Raptor sort of running out of the
cage I was able to push everything back
and grab one of these poor workers I
think there is a clear product liability
problem with whoever designed this
entrapment system and on top of it the
person that put this park together I
think has some major negligence issues
which will be a running theme throughout
this video this thing easily could have
been designed in such a way to prevent
the cage from moving back away from the
wall and keeping all of these
individuals safe just make it all
automated and use mechanics and
hydraulics instead of requiring a human
to open and close this cage and stand on
top of it this kind of foreseeable
injury is exactly what negligence is
made to protect against and this is a
bad system on delivery 50,000 more
viable how am I supposed to transport
them
can even check it if they want 36 hours
no ma'am Pam the embryos have to be back
here in San Jose by then that's up to
your guy on the boat 7 o'clock tomorrow
night on the east dock make sure he gets
it right all right what we have here is
a civil and criminal conspiracy between
these two individuals to engage in a
number of different crimes and business
torts what Dodgson and Ned jury are
doing here is they are conspiring to
steal the trade secrets of Hammond and
engine which constitutes the criminal
act of theft and it also constitutes the
civil wrong of conversion conversion is
the civil version of theft so they're
trying to steal these dinosaur embryos
from Jurassic Park
now given that Dodgson is paying Nedry
millions of dollars to engage in this
theft and this conspiracy we can
reasonably say that the value of the
things that an entry is stealing are
worth at least as much as he's getting
paid so millions if not tens of millions
of dollars given the dollar amounts at
issue this theft gets enhanced into the
felony of grand larceny which carries
with it easily five to 20 years in jail
depending on the circumstances on top of
that they are engaging the civil
conspiracy to steal trade secrets which
carries with it a hefty civil fine along
with it so that is just the beginning of
the crimes that both of those guys are
gonna be on the hook for I'll tell you
the problem with the scientific power
that you're that you're using here it
didn't require any discipline to attain
it you know you read what others had
done and you then you took the next step
you didn't earn the knowledge for
yourselves so you don't take any
responsibility for it you're stood on
the shoulders of geniuses to accomplish
something as fast as you could and
before you even knew you had you you
and packaged it and slapped it on a
plastic lunchbox and now selling your
Selleck well I I don't think you're
giving us our due credit our scientists
have done things which nobody's ever
done before yeah yeah but your
scientists were so preoccupied with
whether or not they could they didn't
stop to think of they should so Malcolm
raises a really interesting point the
dinosaurs in this park are not naturally
occurring animals like you would find in
a zoo these are essentially products
that they created when you put a product
whether it is a car or a pharmaceutical
drug into the stream of Commerce you are
often responsible for the damages that
occur as a result of that particular use
and at Jurassic Park the products are
the dinosaurs they have packaged it into
a theme park like environment but if a
drug needs to carry with it a warning
that there are side effects you can
imagine what kind of warnings would be
necessary for Tyrannosaurus Rex or any
of the other dinosaurs on this this
island I don't believe you all meant to
come down here and defend me against
these characters and the other one I've
got on my side is the blood sucking
lawyer I take offense at that about 75
miles west of us keep an eye on it maybe
it'll swing south like the last one
so a tropical storm is going to hit
Jurassic Park this can actually cut in
two different ways here on the one hand
if you build a theme park off the coast
of Costa Rica you should expect to deal
with hurricanes every once in a while on
the other hand there is a concept in the
law called force maggiore which is
basically an act of God which is so
unforeseeable that no one can really be
held responsible so you might argue that
this particular hurricane might be so
severe and so unusual that there's no
way Hammond could have planned for it
and that he's not responsible for the
things that go wrong as a result of this
particular tropical storm or hurricane
so those are the two ways that it could
go I'm not sure which way comes out in
this particular case we'll see
oh well I finished debugging the phones
uh you know I was gonna die so I did the
phones and I thought maybe you should
tell you that the system is going to be
compiling for 18 to 20 minutes so some
of the minor systems they might go on
and off for a while it's nothing to
worry about it's a simple thing all
right so Nedry has engaged in probably
what constitutes a number of different
computer and hacking crimes he has
clearly exceeded his authorization
regarding the Jurassic Park computer
network he is using it for his own
nefarious purposes and not only that but
he's endangering the lives of everyone
on this tour but because he has exceeded
his authorization for the network he's
essentially trespassing to all of the
different computers and the locks and
electronic systems on Jurassic Park he's
also engaged in Computer Fraud basically
by using a computer for fraudulent
purposes on top of that the hacking
itself is part of his scheme to steal
the trade secrets and the biological
embryos from Jurassic Park so it's part
of this larger conspiracy to commit
grand larceny so now would probably be a
good time to tell you about the felony
murder rule because I think it's going
to be relevant in this particular
context the felony murder rule states
that if you commit an inherently
dangerous felony and during the course
of that felony someone is killed you are
on the hook for first-degree murder
which is the worst kind of murder that
the law recognizes it's essentially the
premeditated killing it's like an
assassination you intended to kill the
particular victim the felony murder rule
is an exception to the general rule that
to commit first-degree murder you have
to have that mens rea of that
intentionality of killing that person
and often that is how you get the death
penalty in states that still have the
death penalty so if I was a prosecutor
and I was trying to prosecute Nedry to
the maximum extent possible I would
argue that theft in this particular case
grand
and conspiracy to commit grand larceny
are one of the things that qualify as
being inherently dangerous and Nedry
might be on hook for the first-degree
murder of the people that die during the
course of his attempted theft
I don't feel like this is an accurate
portrayal of attorneys where does he
think he's go then you gotta go you got
[Music]
alright so the t-rex has broken out of
its paddock because the electricity went
down and the fence is no longer
electrified to me this situation screams
negligence negligence is one of the
first things you learn about in law
school to prove negligence you have to
show a duty between one person and
another you have to have a breach of
that Duty you have to have a causation
between the breach of that Duty and the
damages suffered and you have to have
actual damages duty is important because
strangers don't owe each other anything
if the classic example is if you saw
someone drowning in a pool you don't
have an affirmative obligation to help
that person you probably should but
legally speaking you generally don't
have a requirement to do so unless
there's some obligation to affirmatively
act that's what a duty is and when you
create a theme-park you have a duty to
your tourist the the people that are in
that Park whether you have breached your
duty depends on whether you have upheld
the standards of someone else in your
position in other words what would a
reasonable proprietor of a theme park do
did the damages that the harm that
someone incurred did that result from
the foreseeable results of someone's
actions so looking at it in this
particular context we have a
Tyrannosaurus Rex in a paddock they have
taken precautions to make sure that the
t-rex doesn't get out they've put an
electrified fence containing this t-rex
and when that fence is electrified the
t-rex doesn't get out it knows that it's
going to get shocked and the shocks are
enough to keep it inside however can we
expect things to go wrong is it
foreseeable that the fence might not be
electrified at all times I would say yes
a hundred percent so what should you do
as the proprietor of a dinosaur theme
park well you should take precautions to
make sure that if the electricity goes
down the t-rex still can't get out what
that means in practice is maybe a second
fence one that is able to withstand the
might of the t-rex it seems
like the t-rex here was able to put its
mass in or use its it's tiny you know
arm claws to be able to snap the steel
cables here which means that they could
have used offense with stronger steel
cables separately maybe you have a
backup generator that goes into effect
immediately when the first line of
electricity goes down that's a different
way that you can solve this problem a
third way to prevent this problem would
be to not use a fence at all I've been
to many zoos that have very large
animals like elephants and giraffes
where those animals are far below where
the tourists are so the the change in
elevation is big enough that there's no
way for the animal to get to the high
ground where all the people are so the
natural barriers the difference in
elevation is enough to keep the animals
from attacking the tourists and the
sightseers so those are three different
ways that the designers of Jurassic Park
could have designed this particular
enclosure to keep the tourists safe and
there's any really no question that this
negligence resulted in the injuries that
these people are going to suffer the
emotional distress and the physical
injuries that they're going to suffer
are a direct result of the t-rex getting
out so there's a direct causal link
what's called proximate cause under the
law between the negligence in question
and their injuries so this is a
slam-dunk case I think against Jurassic
Park for pure negligence bordering on
recklessness for these these poor people
in these cars
nice boy so we have the situation where
we have a really bad actor who is going
to suffer some physical injuries spoiler
alert
as a result of his own bad acts but also
partially as a result of some of the
negligence of the park owners so in this
particular situation it's possible that
if he were able to sue as a result of
his injuries and not being eaten alive
by a dinosaur he might be able to get
some recovery yes he was partially
responsible but in most jurisdictions
they use what's called comparative fault
which means that if you are at fault for
a certain bad thing happening to you and
someone else is also responsible for
that thing well you just look at the
various percentages and you say okay
well if it was a 50/50 split then you're
entitled to recover 50% of the actual
damages that is in contrast to what
states used to use which is called
contributory negligence which is that if
you're responsible for even 1% of your
own damages you're not entitled to
receive anything there are pros and cons
with both situations but equity
generally is in favor of comparative
negligence instead so Nedry might be
able to file suit however on the other
hand there is a doctrine called unclean
hands which says that you're not able to
profit from your own bad acts and
nedra's acts are so bad in this case I
think he would probably be precluded
from recovering anything
so nedra passes away as a result of his
own bad acts but interestingly because
he entered into a conspiracy conceivably
the other members of this conspiracy
might be responsible for Ned jury's
death both civilly and criminally as
well
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh boy
alright now just as it is foreseeable
that the electricity is going to go down
on these electrified fences it's also
foreseeable that a human might be able
to touch these fences as well so not
only do you need the electric fence to
keep the dinosaurs in but you also have
to have a way to keep the humans away
from this electrified fence as well yet
another reason why these electrified
fences were just a bad bad idea in the
first place the question is is it
foreseeable that a human would ever
touch these fences well as we saw from
earlier in this movie it was incredibly
easy for the characters to leave the
cars when they wanted to one precaution
you could take is to make it so that no
one can leave the cars as they're taking
the tour that might open up a whole
bunch of other problems but at least it
would prevent people from touching the
fence here in this particular iteration
we see that it's very easy for people to
leave and there is nothing preventing
these people from touching these
electrified fences so it I think it is
incredibly foreseeable that someone some
person might accidentally touch the
electrified fence and be shocked in the
same way that Tim was here
[Music]
[Music]
okay I suppose this is a minor thing in
the context of island full of dinosaurs
killing people but those fossils
probably weigh thousands and thousands
of pounds I don't think that they should
be buckling under the additional weight
of a couple of people and the fact that
they're falling apart is yet more
evidence of negligence by the park
owners here so given the height that
those two characters fell from I think
we can safely add a sprained ankle and
perhaps a broken foot to the pain and
suffering and medical bills that
Jurassic Park is responsible for that is
one big pilot all right welcome to
Jurassic Park Jurassic Park let's tally
up the crimes here the main bad actor is
Ned jury he engaged in multiple criminal
acts first he attempted to steal trade
secrets from the company given the value
of the larceny I would peg his sentence
at 20 years on top of that during the
commission of this felony that was
inherently dangerous three people died
including Muldoon Arnold and the lawyer
people dying given the felony murder
rule Nedry would be guilty of three
counts of first degree murder the worst
kind of murder and he would certainly be
sent to jail for the rest of his life if
not put on death row effectively serving
three back-to-back life sentences
[Music]
regarding John Hammond as the owner of
Jurassic Park I don't think he would be
criminally liable they clearly didn't
intend for any of this to happen so they
lack the mens rea ax for most criminal
acts but that being said their gross
negligence is clearly apparent skimping
out on dinosaur proof fences and not
creating a backup system for when those
fences were no longer electrified is
clearly an act of negligence and they
are responsible for the civil damages
that occurred included in that are
probably the wrongful deaths of the
three people that died which include
Muldoon Arnold and the lawyer as well
not to mention the OSHA violations at
the beginning of the movie which led to
the poor Park worker being eaten alive
by a raptor so that's four counts of
wrongful death how much a jury would
award would depend largely on their
lifetime earning capacity but let's
conservatively say five million dollars
per person on top of that there is the
pain and suffering and medical bills for
all of the other people that went to the
park under false pretenses
so let's peg that at about a million
dollars per person so add it all
together that is 25 million dollars that
Jurassic Park owes to these surviving
members of the excursion and the family
members of those that didn't quite make
it all the way through Jurassic Park
decided not to win doors to park now if
you're going to start a dinosaur theme
park that may or may not kill all of its
patrons you're going to need a website
to advertise it when I needed a website
for helping law school students which
for the record contains no dinosaurs
I chose Wix Wix helped me create an
e-commerce store and a law school blog
I've used them for years and have paid
them with my own money because I
actually like the websites that I
created I looked at other website
builders but they were all too
constricting the templates were fine but
I couldn't change them how I wanted to
Wix allowed me to build an awesome
professional website that let me be as
creative as I wanted and the
click-and-drag interface is so easy even
a velociraptor could do it if you are
looking to build your own website you
have to check out Wix the first 100
legal eagles will get 10% off just click
the link below and use the code legal
eagle at checkout so get out there make
a website for an on murdery version of
Jurassic Park with Wix and until next
time I'll see you in court